معنا من نعمان الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي اللواء فايز الدويري وفايز
اذا تتابع ما يجري من خلال هذه الاخبار
حديث عن حشد
رهيب من قبل الجانب الروسي قد يصل الى 500
الف جندي
وتقديرات بان قد يكون هناك اجتياح حتى
يطال العاصمه
هل نحن امام سيناريو في هذا الاتجاه ام
هناك قراءه مختلفه
يعني اذا اذا كانت المعلومات دقيقه رقم
500 الف تحدثنا عنه في بدايه الحرب ان اي
عمليه ناجحه
وتحقق اهدافها تحتاج الى
500 الف وهذا الرقم بالضبط
ذكر سابقا الان هل هذه المعلومه يقينيه هل
الاستخبارات تؤيد هذا الشيء
والان الحديث عن ثلاث جبهات في الشرط هي
الجبهه فاعله وتحقق انجازات في الجنوب لا
وجود لها اذا قصدنا الجنوب اوديسيا في
الشمال هناك حديث عن
مناورات مشتركه قوه مشتركه قوامها 15 الف
الان اذا كان هناك هجوم جديد
باتجاه كيف يجب ان لا يقل حجم القوه عن
150 الف جندي حتى يتم تجنب الاخفاق الاول
تعتمد على متغيرات
المتغيرات اولا الطقس والاعداد البحري لان
عمليه استهداف اوديستا تحتاج الى عمليه
انزال بحري او ما يسمى بعمليات الابرار
يبقى الحديث يتركز على شرق نهر
شرق نهر الديوبر هناك انجازات هذه
الانجازات تراكميه وقد تشهد اذا ما استمرت
هذه الانجازات قد تشهد الاسابيع القادمه
عمليه تطوير شامل لمعارك الشرق وهنا يجب
ان نتحدث عن كامل عن زبروجيا كامله وقد
نبدا بالحديث عن دينابرو اي بمعنى اخر ان
تحاول ان تسيطر على شرق نهر الدينيبر الذي
يشمل
واجزاء كبيره من خرسون هذا الامر الخيار
الثالث هو الخيار المرجح بالنسبه لي حتى
هذه اللحظه بناء على المعطيات الواقعيه
والموثقه اما ما الحديث عن ال500 الف لا
نزال ننتظر عمليه تاكيد ذلك من مصدرين
هامين هو السي اي ايه
والاستخبارات البريطانيه
العسكريه والاستراتيجيه اللواء فايز
الدويري كنت معانا من عمان شكرا جزيلا لك